[Music]
you all are in an absolutely
wonderful place
in your career i know it's hard work and
you struggle to get in here and there's
probably times you wonder whether
this whole experience was was worth it
cost you time and money to come here
but
i think when you look back on this
experience at stanford the connections
that you made the classmates that you
met
and the things that you learned while
you were here i think you will
absolutely find that this was well worth
the sacrifice to come here and complete
the program
having said that
it also puts you in a very unique place
and it's
why i i choose to take the tack i do
with these remarks
because
contrary to most other times in your
career you are at an ideal point if if
you choose to do it
to kind of hit the reset button on your
career which you know an mba
or a mid-career master's
any other graduate degree that has a
break from your work
and has you come out different than when
you went in
gives you this opportunity to hit the
reset button
and do something different
now there are some limitations on how
far a field from where you've been that
you can
easily go
you can do you can go a little more
a field
with more and more and more difficulty
nothing is impossible especially for
stanford graduates as we all we all know
but one of the things i want to try to
touch on here today a little bit
is
what's easy
and what's hard
and then you can choose you know where
in that spectrum of things that
that you want to position yourself and
maybe we'll have some tips in terms of
how to do it and in the q a
uh fire away i always get some
interesting questions i'll do the best i
can to be
to be dead honest with you because the
last thing you need
from anybody like me is some platitudes
about how easy something is going to be
when it's hard or how
something that you think you want to do
isn't going to work
and or probably won't work and if that's
the case i'm just going to tell you that
and you know you can value the advice of
what it costs you
to get us started
i thought i would go through about a
dozen slides
this will be real quick but there's some
things in here that i hope get you
thinking a little bit
and
maybe uh cause a question or two
that we can deal with later because i
really want the bulk of the time here to
be devoted to your questions
and
my experience has been your questions
generate other questions and the
audience starts to play off each other
and we have a little fun
but let me run through this fairly
quickly if you have a question about the
slides feel free interrupt me on this is
really informal i don't we don't have to
hold everything until the end but i i'd
like to try to set the stage a little
bit with just some initial thoughts that
i call launching or relaunching an
executive career
and there we go
so here's a here's a pretty obvious
statement and we'll start with an easy
when companies are formed
and built
and grown
on three legs of a three-legged stool
ideas money and talent
those are the three things that's all
there is
so what about these three things ideas
ideas are never in short supply as i
said here there's almost an infinite
number of ideas for product service and
technology in the world and every time
somebody makes a stupid statement that
everything important in this field is
invented virtually the next day somebody
comes up and proves them wrong with a
new idea and has everybody saying yeah i
never thought of that wish i had money
money you need money to build businesses
but money's normally in in pretty
adequate supply
in every business cycle good ideas get
funded and then some of them as we've
seen over and over again lousy ideas get
funded but good ideas can always find
funding somewhere so what's the shortage
the shortage is you
the shortage is talent
it's in limited supply it's finite
at the leadership level it's not only
finite it's declining
as baby boomers who have been the
the leadership
core
of the world for the last 20 years my
generation are getting out of these jobs
and
doing things like this talking to people
like you who are taking over for for my
generation
and
you can't make more
there's only that many people of that
age and that talent
and so
what that says is this leadership
shortage which is going to be forever
is really good news for you
if you have a compelling story and if
you tell your story the right way to the
right people
it doesn't matter how good your story is
if you don't tell it to anybody that can
help you
and
if you have a lousy story and you tell
it to the wrong people that's not going
to get you anywhere anyway
so
what about resumes i'm asked a lot of
times about resumes
and i
probably
pay less attention to resumes than than
most people do
you got to have one
um
maybe
i mean frankly today
your linkedin profile may be good enough
for most of the things that
that you've got to do if you don't have
a linkedin pro profile you've got to get
one and do that do that quick make sure
it's always current and make sure it's
always accurate beyond a resume
this is a document that helps you tell
your story
and it'll help you if you have a good
story to tell and if you tell it right
so what makes a good story
well in my opinion
good choices
because you're going to have to be
explaining them with logical
explanations because in your career
you're going to be faced with a number
of times where you're going to be
sitting down across the table from
somebody
that you want to convince they ought to
do something positive for you and
they're probably going to look at your
background and look at your resume and
start asking you questions like well why
did you do that
why did you make that choice
why did you go here instead of there
why didn't you stay and get promoted in
this job
if in fact you were doing as good as you
tell me
you you were
companying people over product and
compensation i generally advise people
to go work for the best people they can
work
for and for the best companies they can
work for
if the product's not right
and it's a good company and you're
working for great people that'll get
fixed over time
if the if it's the greatest product in
the world and you're working for lousy
people they'll find a way to mess it up
and you'll be on the outs
venture capitalists understand this all
too well i mean one of the oldest
sayings in the venture capital world
is
a an a management team with a b product
will find a way to make their investors
money
and a b management team with an a
product will find a way to mess it up
i mean and that's how they invest you
look at their record and you'll see it
it's people
measurable accomplishments and
promotions
if if you can focus on anything when
you're putting your story together
focus on
what you have accomplished that you can
legitimately take credit for or at least
partial credit for
and be clear which is which when you're
explaining it that's measurable with
facts and figures and things that people
will recognize and ideally which got you
promoted
credible transitions and moves as i said
you're going to be explaining
your moves
uh over time to people who are not going
to
take [ __ ] or fluffy
answers and pay much attention to them
so
think
about that before you make a transition
or a move and certainly as you're making
it how you're going to be explaining it
10 15 20 years down the road
recognized mentors and references
as as you're building a career you're
going to work for people and whether you
like it or not the reputation of those
people rubs off on you if it's good it
helps you if it's bad it hurts you
and there's not a whole lot that you can
do about that other than to be smart in
your choices
and if you find that you're working for
somebody
whose reputation is likely to hurt you
because their reputation is bad
get out
get away
or get out and do it as fast as you can
and finally
what makes a good story when you're
telling it to somebody is at the end of
the day at the end of the conversation
you've got to be able to convince them
that you can be successful doing
something that in fact they want done
because if you can convince them that
you can do it but it isn't anything that
they need to have done then you don't go
anywhere or if they have something that
they need to have done and you can't
convince them that you can do it it
doesn't go on anywhere it's only when
you put those two things together
that telling your story
to somebody that matters and can do
something positive with it will get you
a good outcome
how to tell it well we've touched on
some of this
clear clarity of goals and
accomplishments i'm basically an
advocate of a simple chronological
resume that says what you did when you
did it who you did it for what the
results were and and what happened to
you as a result
i mean if you think about those things
that's that's what i'm always looking
for i don't like a lot of fluffy
explanations
uh of of things that don't matter facts
are good if they're true
promotions are better
accurate facts and dates
easy to pick out successes keep in mind
that you you want somebody who's looking
at your resume
or looking at your linkedin profile to
look at something on there and say aha i
can use that that that fits here that's
interesting
logical transitions
no misrepresentations or vague claims
and a clear incredible path to what you
seek we'll come back to that because
that last point's important and i and
we're going to cover that in the q a
because
it doesn't matter how good your
background is in a conversation that
you're having with somebody about the
potential of working for them
unless you can convince them that that
excellent background fits something that
they need to have done otherwise it's a
nice conversation
they probably like you and say you've
got a great background doesn't fit here
but you know
why are you telling me your story you
should be telling it to somebody who can
do something about it
we talk a lot about networks
most people don't have any idea how big
their networks in fact really are
your networks are enormous
i mean you start with the people in the
room
you start with everybody they know
you start with people that they know
you you look at graduates of stanford
you know people that they know the
places that they've worked before you
know it you can define your network
literally as being hundreds of thousands
of people
because any any anybody who can make a
connection to somebody that might be
willing to help you
is in fact part of your network and you
may not even know who they are
but they're part of your network and you
can make that work for you
if you want to meet somebody
somebody usually somebody in the
stanford business school alumni
community will make that introduction
for you if you can figure out the right
way to get to them and the right way to
ask that question
gsb alums will usually help
i'll make this point because i i always
make it
and that is
almost anybody is going to be willing to
help you
i'd be willing to help you your
classmates will be willing to help you
your professors and alumni will be
willing to help you but very few of them
are going to be willing to do your
homework for you
and so
an example
if you call me and
say tom i want to get into
you know
i don't know
venture capital
would you introduce me to some venture
capitalists
what
that's a lazy question
okay but if you said i've got two years
in the venture capital industry
and
i
worked on a project
that
you know
you know
josh green at more david dao is a board
member of i know you know josh because i
know you work with him on a board
would you be willing to introduce me to
josh uh josh green so that i could have
a conversation about this project that i
know he's interested in okay that now
the night and day those two questions
the first one general requires work on
my part
and i'm not gonna go do a lot of work
to try to figure out what you could have
figured out and didn't
but the second one
if if i believe that that's a very
credible question it takes me about 30
seconds to pop off an email to josh and
say look this is somebody i think i
think you ought to meet and they've
they've specifically picked you out of
the hundreds or thousands of venture
capital people because of your
experience in this company and they're
interested in that and they think they
have something to add would you meet
with them for you know 15 20 minutes
specific on the one hand general on the
other hand
said pick specific targets make specific
requests and then if somebody does you a
favor particularly somebody who didn't
have any reason to do it other than they
were just trying to help you
after the thing is done you met with
josh order go back send them an email
and tell him what happened
hey i met with josh thanks for setting
that up i'm not sure what's going to
come out of it but i really appreciate
it we're going to stay in touch thank
you
believe me that will pay dividends later
first of all it's just good common
courtesy if somebody did something for
you that they didn't have to do to call
them up and thank them and tell them
what happened because they're probably
curious it also leaves that door open
to go back to them again in the future
because they've got a good good feeling
about you this is somebody that handled
that right and they'd be willing to go
do another favor for you down the road
whereas
you know i've got a lot of people i i
won't name them maybe i will later if
you but
who seems like every couple of years
would call me up and say tom
it's been so long since we've talked i
would really want i really wanted to get
back to you and see how you were doing
well i'm doing fine
how are you doing well you know i didn't
work out i was looking for a job but
what happened with the last thing that
you called me about two years ago that
you never came back and told me what
happened about that
and
you know
maybe i'll be polite to them maybe i
won't more likely they don't somehow i'm
out of town
or something when that call comes in and
and my ea just handles it and it never
sees the light of day
stay connected to the people who have
helped you
now my career was in the executive
search business i started uh
very early uh i was i think i was like
32 i spent 30 years with heidrick and
struggles we were the largest search
firm in the world for a long time i
think pretty much the most respected
senior executive search firm in the
world then and now i did a lot of things
with the firm including uh spending the
last five years before i retired from
that as as chairman and ceo we were a
public company by then with
70 offices in 40 countries and 500 and
some partners spread out all over the
place
and
it's amazing to me that so many people
who interact with executive search firms
don't have hardly any clue about how the
profession works and what it does and
what it doesn't do and how it can how it
can work for you
let me give you an example
there's
thousands of of search firm partners
and you know my firm had about 500 they
were spread out all over the world but
for any one particular thing
particularly at the very senior level
where recruiters in every firm begin to
specialize on industry and function
for somebody in this audience there
might have been in my firm
three four maybe five
of the 500 recruiters that it would be
useful to build a relationship with
and
495
who
might like you might be friends might be
a neighbor might help you a different
way i'll come back to that
but would never be in a position to have
an assignment where you could be a
candidate
because maybe you're a
chief consumer products chief marketing
officer
and your next-door neighbor is a partner
at one of the big five
executive recruiting firms and does
chief information officer searches for
industrial companies
pretty much only and dominates that
space
there is zero chance that that that
person will ever have a direct
assignment that you can be a candidate
for
but
that person knows those five people
who are the five people in that firm
that you ought to get to know
and the way to use them if you can get a
relationship with them is tell them
exactly
either what kind of person or if you can
do your research it's usually not very
hard what specific person in their firm
you'd like to get introduced to and
they'll probably do that for you because
it's it's it's the stock and trade
recruiters work
work for clients
we work exclusively for clients but we
have this kind of odd three-party
symbiotic relationship it's completely
unique in professional service
representation where
we get paid by one
side of a transaction
but have to be perceived as fair
balanced and delivering value to both
sides
lawyers don't get that i mean you got
you got two companies fighting with each
other company a's got a lawyer company
b's got a lawyer the lawyers fight with
each other but they know who they're
they know who they're representing
they're not trying to be fair they're
advocates they're advocates for their
side you know marketing people pr people
you know accountants they're working for
their clients and every client has one
of those but the search the search
profession is is pretty odd
so
the people that do would have to tread
this line between loyalty to a client
and respect and loyalty among the
candidates because unless they can put a
transaction together
with two willing parties who are both
smart
and ideally not going to do something
that's not in the both of their best
interests
no transaction happens no search gets
completed and
nothing gets done and that person
doesn't stay in the business very long
so you can make that work for you
as long as
you understand
that it's not the recruiter's job to
find you your next position it's a
recruiter's job
to solve the problem
that their client has
and if you can be the solution to that
problem then they're going to be real
happy to bring you forward
and have you be a candidate for that
project if you're not the solution to
that problem
two things can happen if you recognize
it early on and raise your hand and say
this isn't right for me what i'm really
interested in is x
uh let me try to help you with a
suggestion of somebody better than me
for this project and would you remember
me for something or introduce me to one
of your colleagues who's working on what
i want to do that's a good interaction
that will serve you well
what won't serve you well is either
trying to convince a recruiter any
recruiter really at any level that
you're something that you're not because
they'll figure it out eventually
or that you
are interested in something that in the
end you're really not interested in
because you're wasting the recruiters
time which is the only asset they have
to make a living with and they don't
appreciate it when their time is wasted
uh they know every every uh set of
interactions is not going to lead to a
successful outcome and you may go all
the way to the end and you may decide or
the client may decide this isn't right
it didn't happen but as long as that was
done with good faith nobody has any hard
feelings but if it was done with bad
faith and bad faith can be on the client
side too i've experienced this as well
in which case i apologize to the cli to
the to the candidates and try to make it
right if i can but
nobody worries about that as long as
everybody is proceeding
along the path with good faith
be specific be special
try to be very clear
when you're dealing with recruiters of
any kind what it is that you want what
you're willing to do what you're not
willing to do
and you know be asked ask the kind of
questions to try to decide if this
opportunity that they've put in front of
you or called you about
is is the right potential one for you if
it is say so don't be cute don't play
hard to get
be honest and it would be plenty of time
for negotiation at the end
if it isn't pull out fast and uh and
don't waste your time
don't lie or embellish
your resume
my colleagues and i spent years
honing skills to smell [ __ ] coming a
mile away i mean a good recruiter will
not let you get away with claiming
something
that isn't true
that's fluffy credit for something that
really maybe you had a small part of and
you're trying to take too much credit
for you don't need to do that you've got
good records just be honest and and try
to position yourself someplace where
your
skill set and your interests fit what
the clients need needs
we've covered some of this other stuff
the second one though i want to come
back to because
as you think about what it is that you
want to do there is a role there for
executive recruiters to play over a long
period in your career and the key i
think for all of you is to figure out
literally that handful
and it's probably no more than that in
any particular geography if you go more
broadly global it could be a little more
it's still not a big number and i doubt
i doubt for most of you
the
critical mass of recruiters among the
major search firms who would be in a
position to be really good
career
long allies and sources for you i would
be
very surprised if that was more than 10
or 12
people in total
that's a number of people that you can
over time get to know
it's not hundreds that's hard but you
know 10
6 8 10 12 you can do that
particularly if you identify who they
are and have a strategy to get to know
them in a positive way through
introductions of people other search
people others who will help you but get
to know them in a positive way stay
connected don't be a pain in the neck
but stay connected and and build a very
long-term relationship with them
particularly the ones that are working
in your chosen field
a level or two above where you are now
because over time they'll move up too
and as you move up you'll be heading
into there into their space
from from below as as it will and those
are the people you want to be dealing
with not the ones that are working at or
below your level now which by the time
you get your next promotion you've
outgrown them and they can't help you
anymore so
you want to be aiming high
so what is what do companies want when
they when they when they're hiring
people
companies in every cycle are hiring
people they're trying to hire good
people
well a they want to
they want to understand what your career
is and how it fits with them
they're looking for skills and
experience that closely match their
needs as as they see them
and probably you can't do a whole lot to
convince them
to see it some other way
this third one's really important
because
anybody
even the ceo
hiring somebody has got an answer to his
his or her board and everybody else has
a boss
maybe more than one boss and if they're
going to hire you
they got to go explain to somebody else
probably somebody you never met maybe
you met him but maybe you didn't why
they want to hire you as opposed to
somebody else and it's your job if you
want that job to make it easy for them
to explain to whoever they have to
explain to why it is that they want to
hire you as opposed to anybody else that
they might hire so if you put yourself
in that mindset and say you gotta you
gotta tell a story not only will they
believe but that they can retell
because they're gonna have to they're
gonna have to justify this decision to
somebody and so the easier you can make
that for them the more likely they are
to hire you which says
personality and style that fits their
culture
every company has has a culture some
cultures are more comfortable for some
people than others some companies are
more female friendly than others some
are more
ethnically open than others some are
more open to different nationalities
than others you can fight that
we can all deplore that and say that's
horrible
but you're looking for a job and uh i
mean if you if you go back to
uh one of the things that i've always
loved that uh that my good friend jim
collins jim probably speaks around here
once in a while
it's fond of saying is it says look for
the open door
he said so many people go through their
lives spending an awful lot of energy
trying to pound their way through doors
that are closed and locked
it's possible but it's hard
down the hall
three doors down maybe there's an open
door with somebody there that would say
come on in
you know once in a while you may want to
think about maybe i'll go down there and
go through that open door as opposed to
trying to pound my way through this one
that's locked or locked to me
now it may be locked to me for reasons
that i find reprehensible
yeah you can decide if you want to try
to change that good luck to you
or you can say you know i'll do that in
my spare time but i need a job so i want
to go someplace where somebody wants me
for what i am for who i am
and they like what i am as opposed to me
trying to convince them they should like
what i am
when they don't
um simple as that
no side issues or hassles the more the
easier you make it to recruit you
the more likely it is that somebody is
going to do that because this gets back
again to they got to go explain this to
somebody else if they want somebody to
start
you know the first of next month
and you don't want to start for three
months that's a problem for them
particularly if they've got another
candidate might not be as good as you
that's willing to start when they want
if you need a lot more compensation than
they're prepared to pay or you have a
whole lot of other complicated things
that they have to deal with that's hard
so the point there is think about what
it is somebody said the difference
between what you'd like to have and what
you need to have focus on that make it
easy to hire you compensation demands
they can meet yeah
you know
sometimes you can push the boundaries
we've got another little uh
presentation i do on negotiating
compensation i don't think we're gonna
have time to do that tonight but we
could if anybody has any questions about
that we'll handle it in the q a
and once somebody hires you they want
you to go they want you on board you
should want that too but they want you
on board starting and engaged
so we're in silicon valley and many of
you either have
uh working startups in fact how many of
you have worked in startups
uh not too many uh usually it's more
okay how many of you are thinking about
working in startups
okay
let me i don't know if i got the match
right how many of you who have worked in
startups before are thinking about going
back into startups again
one two three okay good so you didn't
get
you didn't get turned off it by the
first time
some somebody asked uh i
i'm not sure who it was it might have
been john doerr kleiner perkins said if
one time he said if you're trying to
figure out
if you're an entrepreneur
you're not
which i always thought was kind of
interesting
if you need structure
there's nothing wrong with that big
companies need a lot of people they're
good places to work
and if if that's you
that's fine go big
lots of big companies recruiting here
lots of big companies are great places
to to work for entire careers
if you decide to go to a startup i would
i would pose not not for everybody but
for the people in this room because
you're special
you're a special group of people i would
say
if it's a startup you want to be focused
on a couple of things and i say will you
be at the table
at the table means are you going to be
in the group
the small group of people that makes the
key decisions
that are in a closed room with the door
closed when something big is coming down
and bet the company or really important
decisions have to be made
if you're at that table it doesn't
matter a whole lot what your job title
is what your compensation is really or
anything else because it'll all be taken
care of
if you're not at the table
and you're outside looking through the
keyhole trying to figure out what's
going on in that room when the key
decisions are being made
i would say to you if it's a startup
most of the time the risk-reward ratio
for you is not right
you know that that puts you in in in the
world of four box matrixes
in the high risk low reward box and i
don't think that's a box
that you ought to be intentionally
aiming yourself to
that if the company is wildly successful
you make a little bit of money
and you weren't really part of the the
team that drove it
on the other hand if you're in the high
risk high reward box
yeah that could be great
can you handle the risk
what will you do if it fails
some cultures
some geographies
failure's really hard
it's really hard to explain or somebody
said once are you going to go home and
tell your mother
that your company failed
if you grew up around silicon valley it
was like okay big deal what are you
going to do next but there's some places
in the country and in the world where
you know that that's going to be really
hard for you and if it if it is and you
don't feel like you're up for it maybe
that's not where you ought to go
are the leaders of the startup
professionals or are they friends
i i put up a big red flag every time i
see a startup that's three college
roommates that get together because they
want to start a company and i'll be the
ceo and so you be the marketing vp and
what do you want to be okay uh
engineering yeah well we gotta have one
okay well you're really not very good
that's a bad way to get a company
started
and if you get into a company where
where the
officers are friends
and they wouldn't be picked for their
talent in a fair fight against other
people
this has a very high probability of
coming out with the worst possible
outcome you could imagine which is you
lose the company you lose the job and
you probably lose your friends
uh in in in the process so i just say
massive caveats on going in any startup
where a bunch of your friends get
together and choose upsides is the
financing solid for at least a year
um because you don't want to be coming
into something
unless there's at least a year of runway
there before the company needs to raise
money
because
maybe it won't and that's and that's
tough
as i said if it's a tough choice
say no i think we had like two slides
left and we're going to q a i knew you
had lee did you have a question you
wanted to ask before you left
you'll catch
me contrary to somebody who i recruited
ceos mostly for a living and there's a
popular wisdom that you really want to
go out when you're looking for a ceo and
find somebody that's done this
successfully two or three times and
that's that's the spiel we gave to our
clients it was a big part of our sale
they bought it most of the time
it wasn't true
uh the fact of the matter is
most successful ceos that you could
think about and that you could identify
did the job
they succeeded the first time they tried
it most of them never did it again
um a few did
generally with less success than they
did the first time but a few is very few
successful
successive entrepreneurs of ceos of
multiple things
i said experience counts but the best
succeed the first time
here's where i say
and this is contrarian thinking and it's
contrary into the experience most of you
will have where you'll have a lot of
jobs you'll work for a number of
companies and your 10 years you know
maybe fairly short and they're getting
shorter in in this day and age
but i urge you each time that you think
about taking a job whether it's the one
you get out of here when you reach hit
that reset button or each subsequent
time
i urge you to at least put some of your
effort into the thought process that
this is the last
change i'm ever going to make and i'm
going to work for this company for the
rest of my working career i'm going to
run it one day
and then i'm going to retire from it
having spent my whole career here
chances are pretty good it won't happen
but that mindset will serve you well no
matter what it happened to me wasn't my
first time was my second time i found
something that i really liked i stayed
with the company for 30 years i ran it i
retired from it so i i admit my bias is
characterized by my personal experience
which i freely admit but
don't go work for a company that
you don't respect
that you can't go home to your family
and tell them what they do
and have them feel good about that
it's not on the slide but don't go work
for a company if you won't
relocate to where the corporate
headquarters is
i can't tell you how many times and i've
got this story and it is so obvious that
i have to tell it i was interviewing a
guy some years ago
who was a extremely successful
regional
manager for medtronic
great company wonderful company he was
in washington dc running the eastern
eastern region and
they wanted him to move to minneapolis
which is where the company was
headquartered
and he didn't want to do that
because he wanted to stay in washington
and i asked him i said
you know
how is this not predictable
i mean the only way that eventually
you're not going to get asked to go to
the corporate headquarters is if a the
company's
fails or gets sold or b you're not very
good
and if you're not willing to go where
the seat of power is
why in the world did you spend the last
10 years working your ass off to get to
generate this opportunity which now
you're going to turn down
explain to me how that makes any sense
so think about that
run something hard
my my bias is if you've got an
opportunity
to take a line job over a staff job do
it get p l responsibility
get higher and fire responsibility get
something where you've got budgets to
run people to hire things to manage that
can be measurable if you're successful
and
do the best to avoid things
that
where you your contribution isn't
measurable even if the company is
successful because you'll have you'll
get some
spin-off from being associated with a
successful company but it won't be as
good as if you can demonstrate that
something good happened because you let
it or you did it
the people part
sometimes people tend to think
i don't think anybody here would think
that but sometimes people tend to think
that they don't want to hire really
really good people because it'll
make them look bad or they might
overshadow them or they might be risky
to them
and i'll tell you that's a prescription
i think for failure
because two things
you're not going to get promoted and
this is if you're in a corporate job in
a big company but pretty much anywhere
you're not going to get promoted to the
next big job unless whoever is going to
promote you thinks there's somebody in
your organization that can take over for
you
and if you haven't got anybody well
you'll either
sit in that job until you do
or you'll get passed over because you
aren't perceived
as having good people working for you
so you work for great people they're
going to get promoted they're going to
pull you up behind them you work for you
hire really good people
they'll push you up because they'll be
ready for new challenges you'll give
them to them that reflects well on you
plus it makes you feel good and the last
thing
is
there's nothing that i looked for
and when i scanned resumes and i talked
to people about their background the
first thing
and the last thing and almost everything
in between that i looked at was where
and when did this person get promoted
because you get promoted
when the people or the company that you
work for thought you did a good enough
job and what the job they gave you to
give you a bigger one
and you know it's amazing when i looked
at careers
would see backgrounds
of somebody that starts out
probably not a stanford mba but they
start out as a
you know district sales manager of
company a and then a
a regional sales leader of company b
and then a sales and marketing director
of company c and a vp of sales and
marketing company e and the chief
operating officer of company f looks
like a great progression of titles
they never got promoted never once
so it makes you wonder were they just
getting out of town just before the axe
fell on them and getting lucky to use
their background to get promoted to
another company that would buy
by their story and give them a bigger
job and you look around you'll see
people like this
all the time and they're not the people
you want to go work for for one thing
they're going to be
splitting they're not going to take care
of you because they're only concerned
about themselves and you don't want to
be one of those people so think about
if
if you're close
if you've got an opportunity or you're
thinking about leaving and you're close
to finishing a project you can take
credit for
and getting a promotion
i would urge you think long and hard
before you leave anywhere just short of
a promotion because somebody like me is
going to ask you
why did you leave just short of when you
should have probably gotten promoted
were you going to get promoted
why were you why didn't you get promoted
who got the job in that company that you
would have wanted were they better than
you
so maybe i should be talking to them
so a few final thoughts then we'll go to
q a
the world is big
your world is bigger than most people's
worlds because you have opportunities
that most people don't have
you've earned them by being here by
having the capabilities to get here by
making the sacrifice to come here and so
your opportunity set is large
your networks we talked on this your
networks are much bigger
than your biggest imagination of how big
they can be they're bigger if you think
expansively
people like to help as i said before
make it easy for people to help you
don't make it hard make it easy they'll
do it they'll do it over and over again
and be nice to them
now somebody said be nice to the people
you pass on your way up the corporate
ladder you may you may pass them again
on your way down
but uh
i hope not
but you'll see them again
success is measured in a lot of ways we
can talk about being ceo of a fortune
1000 company and maybe a couple of you
in here will do that but most of you
won't
and that doesn't mean you're less
successful what matters is your success
according to you
not according to me or your classmates
or the school or surveys it what matters
is your success according to you you
measure it your way
and don't let anybody convince you that
you should measure your success in life
any more than your happiness in life by
somebody else's standards
they
they've got their own issues they've got
their own
goals you should have yours and you
should have every reason to expect that
you can
achieve them
last comment is
you know
don't hit the panic button too soon life
is long
enjoy the journey you've got a lot of
great experiences along the way there's
a lot of people that will help you and
appreciate what you do
and i i i can't i wish i was out there
and there's an irish comedian that used
to say gee i wish i was out there in the
audience listening to this but uh
you know in some ways i wish i was out
there with the opportunities that you
all have because i they're they're
really almost limitless and
all i can say is i wish you uh good luck
with them and
we'll be we'll be tracking your progress
[Applause]
hopefully there's hopefully there's
something there that
gets some questions going
yeah
i'm going to talk a little bit about the
process of getting ramped up into a job
search with the recruiter
starting with how you identify those
four or five out of the 500 that are
relevant okay
um
yeah the question the question is how do
you how do you identify the recruiters
who are right for you to begin making a
relationship with over time
um
there's two or three ways and i would i
would try them all
um it it starts by figuring out what it
is that you want to do
and and being as clear and specific
about that as you can and then you get
to people in the recruiting firms and
there's five large ones large global
ones mine was one and then there's you
know a dozen or so mid-tier ones and
then lots of small ones many of whom are
uh founded in the staff by alums of the
big ones so they're just the quality is
just as good they may be they may be
small you start asking people around who
does this kind of work
and you ask enough questions the same
names will come up
second way to do it is
reverse engineer searches it got done
uh if if there's a job out there that
you
would like to have had or would like to
have the next time
and it just got filled you saw the
announcement in the paper chances are
there was a recruiter that did that
search call up the company call up the
individual in the job and say look i see
you got this promotion or sent them an
email
you can reach them on linkedin by the
way we'll come back to that
and say i'm curious as to was there a
recruiter that handled this search and
if so who was it and did were they good
because if they were good for them
they'll be good for you the one thing
about the recruiting profession is once
you start building a reputation for
doing certain kinds of searches
the industry knows
and they'll come back to the same people
time and time again for those projects
that's why they that's how they build
specializations and the same thing
happens within the search firms
i got a lot of calls because i was high
profile from companies wanting searches
done
almost never would i do them so the
question would be who would we recommend
that they talk to and it's going to be
the person in our firm that has the best
track record doing those kinds of
searches and everybody knows who they
are
and so at that point your goal is to
figure out who those people are
and
try to get an opportunity to
have them know who you are
and if they're willing just spend a
little bit of time not a lot of time but
you know 15-20 minutes meeting you
and uh and just saying yeah maybe maybe
i'm not a candidate
for anything right now but i'm a
candidate for what you do as a recruiter
and one of these days you're going to
have an assignment that i'm going to be
qualified for and interested in i wanted
you to know who i was
and that are that that line of
discussion works if you're right if your
facts are right and you've done your
homework it's a waste of time
if it's if it's a random
blast at
the recruiting world
and just as it's pretty much a waste of
time to send resumes to recruiting firms
don't bother it's not worth the paper
you're printing your resumes on they get
tens of thousands most of them
unfortunately go in the go in the scrap
heap including some of the very same
people who come into them through their
sourcing
exercises
uh later on a search that they pay a lot
of attention to they wouldn't have paid
any attention to the resume coming in
because they're not geared
to do the scan and match
by the way
linkedin
is
an excellent way i mean linkedin didn't
exist for most of the years my years in
the recruiting business the search firms
are using linkedin now massively and so
you know you need to make sure that your
linkedin profile is current and is as as
good as it can be
and if you want to get to somebody a
recruiter or somebody that you don't
know
and you don't know what their email
address is if they have a linkedin
account you can send them a linkedin
mail
on the linkedin account and they'll get
it it's it's the best way to reach
somebody that you don't know how to
reach
and so just sort of tuck that away you
can you can do that i think on the basic
free linkedin uh subscription
so many a month some people here
probably know better than i but for a
little bit of money you can move up to
the
to the um higher levels for even if it's
just for a short period of time while
you're doing a job search and you get a
lot more access
that way
so anyway that's what i would do yeah
um my question is uh especially
especially in the valley there's a bit
of a
blurred line uh between what is a
startup and what is established company
we've got
companies growing to hundreds of
millions of dollars in like a year or
two right and so
if i said well there's a company it's
raised series b
financing it's uh it looks very solid
would you say that
so they say like north of 20 million
dollars or 50 million dollars would you
still say that you need to have a seat
at the table there
well that's a mature startup that's
that's not a pure startup
from zero
uh if if they've done a series b and
they've got
financing for
a year or more and they're and they're
growing rapidly
then you might want to you might relax
that because they're going to be hiring
a lot of people and they're not all
going to have a
a seat at the
um
at the key table then the the question
though
to ask is will i have a seat at some
interesting table
um and
does the person that i'm gonna be
working for maybe have a seat at the big
table
um i mean if
if if you're working for somebody
and you won't have a seat at an
interesting table and you're working for
somebody that doesn't have a seat
at the big table
and and but but maybe has heard about
who the people are who do i'm not sure
that's what you want to do but you know
if there's a path the company looks good
you know that that
you're right it's in the fuzzy area
between a small and a big company i was
more talking about a pure
you know seed round or or a round
uh startup which i think is much more
risky than what you just described
yeah either one we'll get the other one
after about the pizza
for international people that we may
have some additional things like we
don't know the culture that much or we
don't know the networks of the industry
that much
uh we have maybe to figure out some
things related with visas
what things can we highlight to stand up
with maybe more
simple
local candidates well sure uh yeah i
think that
almost everybody has some kind of skills
and attributes that other people don't
have
and you're better off
if you can package those and show them
to somebody who has an appreciation for
him
so i mean if you're
if you're not a us national and you have
extensive
international experience either in your
home country or in some third
international country that that's an
asset that companies are looking for
particularly companies who are going to
be expanding international i can help
you
go to
latin america i can help you go to
europe or asia or india and
so
the entry there may well be through
somebody in international
uh
one of the things a lot of people find
is an entry to the bigger companies
is through one of their countrymen
who's a
prior graduate from here who you know
would help them i mean
if you're if you're chilean
uh
you know you want to be making sure that
you're connected you know with the
chilean mba graduate community and the
chilean community of senior executives
here in silicon valley because
my experience is in is they look out for
their countrymen and they'll try to find
a way to help you and then
that translates over to introductions to
other countries and you move to latin
america i'm just using chilean latin
america as an example applies to almost
any anybody anywhere
okay lucky guess
great country by the way
so
you know i think i think that's the case
don't
again back to the open door and the
closed door try to find some open door
where somebody wants to help you for who
you are not wants to slam a door in your
face for who you're not uh and so
i can't emphasize that that's strong
enough find people that are willing to
help you and let them get you through an
open door and then work you around in
the back as opposed to trying to bang
your way in through the front where
maybe they're not not so open yeah you
we missed you it's your turn
valley can abuse failure it's not really
that big a deal it's accepted if you
fail as an entrepreneur
i just want to try and build on that
sentiment because many of us here come
from not an entrepreneurial background
and have come from corporates
um who and have had reasonably
successful careers but are contemplating
as part of a career change here the
stint in entrepreneurship
there is the risk that it could fail and
and so i just wanted to get a sense from
yourself is
to in that point when you're trying to
think through okay go back into a
corporate career and continue the
momentum or take an extent in the
entrepreneurship world and take the
potential risk for the potential reward
not just compensation but also a role
the seat at the table that you mentioned
i'm trying to think how is really in
your opinion
failure perceived because
well it depends on yeah it it depends
it's perceived differently
depending on who's
perceiving it
um
as i said you you graduate from here
you've got the opportunity to hit this
reset this career reset button once
but you don't get an unlimited number of
opportunities to hit that reset button
uh
you might you might get a second
pop at it in a couple years if something
didn't work out but then probably not
the the other comment i would make
is
career transitions that i've watched are
historically quite easy from large
companies to small ones and quite hard
from small ones to large ones and so
if you are going to go from a big
company background into the
entrepreneurial world
think long and hard about that because
it won't be that easy to go back where
you came from
i mean maybe if it's a year or two
and you duck back quick or you go back
to the company you work for you might be
able to do it
but then i would almost say you weren't
really all that committed to going into
the startup world in the first place if
you were looking for an opportunity to
go back like i said if it scares you go
big
um
the
the the failures
particularly in the entrepreneurial
community here
are are really almost no big deal
um
but
they tend to be perceived as a much
bigger deal by the bigger companies the
bigger more mature companies and it's
just a fact of life i think you probably
many of you have probably
experienced that
so
i think the likelihood is if you are
committing to an entrepreneurial career
path
that's a commitment you need to make and
you need to probably
believe
that it's a career-long commitment that
that's where you're going to spend the
rest of your career
god forbid it didn't go well to an
executive search firm who's trying to
fight you the next job well
well a they're not going to be trying to
find you the next job they're they may
be talking to you about a position with
one of their clients in which case
they're already interested in you
so you don't have to you don't you you
they found you somehow
otherwise you didn't get in the door and
you weren't sitting in front of them so
that's a positive
interview if you got it
and then all you have to do i mean if
it's if it's a startup that failed
yeah it's a startup that failed this is
this is what i thought was going to
happen
the questions that i would ask
would be around the choices
and the explanation for the choice you
made to go there not so much the outcome
because you can't control that what you
can control is the choice that you made
to go there and so i i really want to
know well why did you choose to go there
what did you think the likely
outcome was going to be why did you
believe the company was going to be
successful turned out it wasn't but but
those questions can have
very good incredible answers to them
and that's
what you should think about because as i
said that's part of telling your story
and an answer like
they told me it was going to be great
and i didn't really check it
or
one of my friends went there and he said
it was cool
or uh
they had they had a cafeteria where you
could get food like all the time
i mean
those are not very good i'm just i'm
kidding you a little bit but those are
not very good answers
to to questions but an honest assessment
that look i looked at it i thought the
technology was solid they had financing
in place for a year the executive team
was a was an a quality team in in my
estimation and you know it just it
didn't work out
that answer's fine at that point that's
all i want to know and then i'm on to
thinking about well do you fit
you know my next uh my next deal here
and chances are you probably learned
something from that experience which is
also an important thing to to get into
the into the discussion uh who is next i
think maybe you were
um yeah my question is can you speak to
the different hiring practices by
uh geography and by industry so for
example
the bay area seems to be a search firm
averse you know you hire through your
network
whereas you know maybe other industries
are more blue chip but more senior
levels are much more friendly
sure
um
well the first thing i think if you if
you're trying to if you're focused on
particular company or particular set of
companies
um figuring out what their hiring
process is and
who who or what institutions they use to
help them in it
is a good first step and it that's basic
homework and it shouldn't be very hard
you know a few questions
you can call the hr department and talk
to somebody in their recruiting
department they'll they'll tell you the
answers to those questions do you use
recruiters yes or no if you if you do
use recruiters who do you use what do
you use them for what level uh i think
you're you're correct there's a
huge infrastructure
of talent
moving around in silicon valley it's
almost unique in the world
and it's um
it's not that they don't use recruiters
they use everything
and they use everything in volume
uh i mean the recruiting business here
is very strong but so is direct
recruiting i mean most of the major
companies have created big in-house
recruiting staffs
most of those staffs
uh
worked
at one point or other in their
in the big search firms i mean the top
recruiters at apple pretty much all work
for me
uh over the years and
the
in other places though where the
local talent pool is maybe not quite so
vibrant companies will either tend to
rely on recruiters more and that tends
to be the case as you go up more and
more senior levels at the at the officer
level we i just did chief
chief cxo searches and ceo searches for
medium to big companies for the most
part
pretty much all those searches still use
recruiters executive recruiters but
levels below that it's a complete mixed
bag and a lot of it's networking and so
here's where your networks really matter
a lot
is to to tap on both for contacts and to
tap them for information in terms of how
this particular company hires and if you
want to get in the hiring
process and cycle for this company or
this set of companies
how do you do that
and
people will people will tell you and
this is where
uh graduates of this program two three
years out working in these companies who
who sat in these chairs two years ago
and are out doing those jobs now are the
the people that i'd be talking to not me
i'm too far removed from that
but i i i know there are a lot of people
out there who are willing to help you
and they're pretty easily identified
virginia can tell you who they all are
she knows them all and mike they know
them all
uh
i think you were next
okay question is about sourcing
um
recruiters when they do searches use a
variety of techniques one they all have
databases of candidates that they that
they maintain not not so much from
resumes sent to them but by profiles
they've created over the years
candidates they've interviewed
may be presented and want to do present
again because that's
they've got qualified people so they
look at that that's all categorized they
they look at their own
prior search work that's similar where
do we do a search like this the last
time and who were the candidates who
came in second third fourth on on that
search that maybe would be a good fit
for this they do industry sourcing which
is what you talked about where they call
around typically
at a level or two above
what they're what they're trying to find
if if i'm doing a search for a marketing
you know vp
uh i'm calling ceos and saying you know
who who are the best marketing people
you know and your competitors
you know maybe not one of your people
sometimes they'll even suggest one of
their people that
is is blocked
you know surprisingly it happens um
who who's worked for you over the years
that you think is really good and here
this is where if you've worked
for really strong mentors and strong
performers they know about you and if
you stay in touch with them as even if
they've moved on from where you are
they'll think about you they'll
recommend you because they're the people
with the reputations who are going to
get the calls the weak ones don't get
those calls the strong ones get those
calls and are in a position to help
influence the hiring of people that
either they know about or more likely
have worked for them or for their on
their teams over the years and really
good executives i find tend to
take very good care
of people who perform for them over the
years i mean they'll recommend them for
for jobs they'll proactively recommend
them for jobs and in fact if you've got
a good relationship with them you can go
ask them to do that go to somebody who
was a boss of yours in another company
if that was a good relationship he or
she has a good feeling for you call them
and say
look you know i'm ready to make a move
who should i be talking to who in the
search firm world do you know
that you'd be willing to introduce
me to and if somebody reaches out to you
you know
keep me in line
so
well
two things one
if they're if they're international
firms
that have offices in the uk and you have
good relationships with the recruiters
in the uk ask them if they'd be willing
to introduce you to their counterparts
here in silicon valley in their firms
most of them will be willing to do that
um if the firms are large
and and have
offices in in both places if uh
if if not
then
the other the other source is
it could be the uk uh expat community
here you know people people who are
who are who are brits who are working in
silicon valley and there's lots of them
and you know my experience has been
as i as i said before they're they're
willing to help their countrymen because
they know you're in a strange strange
land here and you need a little help so
those two those would probably be my my
two
first
places uh that i would go
beyond just the normal networking that i
talked about before
uh i think you and then you yeah
i'm a little bit personal to ask a
question after your answer with widows
i'm afraid that you can read minds
sometimes so on the topic of magical
powers if you could look into the future
say 20 or 30 years ahead hypothetically
a lot of ceos previously came from
operations and then sales and then the
finance strategy
will there be a change in the origin of
where ceos come from particularly if
they've got a technology background
you know are technologists ever going to
be
never going to have the keys to the
executive washroom
well some some do and some have
i think
technologists are going to
continue to run technology companies
and
if you if you look
at even the near term future most of the
important companies are going to be
technology companies or are going to be
trying to
claim to the world that they're
technology companies even if they're
really not
if you saw the cover article in fortune
this week had a picture of bob iger of
disney
on the cover talking about disney as a
technology company
and his uh his efforts to to remake
disney as a as a technology company
so
bob had no technology in his background
and he's now a technical
guru
i still think as i as i mentioned before
that the people that are going to move
up are the ones that have taken
responsibilities
for
pieces of business and have run them
successfully
and
you can get a business unit
in a larger company or even a smaller
company to run if you set out to do that
pretty early in your career it might not
be a massive one
but you know if you take a small one and
turn it into a medium sized one that's
gonna be that's a pretty good record
then the next time around they give you
a medium-sized one you turn it into a
big one you're successful at that you
can do anything
and so
um i
i
i actually think the question i'd almost
come back at that question and and
reverse it and it's it's not so much
what companies are going to be what what
functional or
areas they're going to be looking
to for their next leaders
they're going to look they're going to
look for leaders
and they're going to take them from
wherever they can find them whatever
they've been doing if they think they
have the leadership capabilities to run
their company or if we think they have
the leadership capabilities to run
another company
but you got to be in a position to have
shown your leadership capabilities
before somebody can look at you and say
this is a leader
who we can give a bigger job to
and
if it's been all staffed that's really
hard
some combination of line and staff if
you've got credible line experience and
some great executives have gone back and
forth between line and staff
and there's a few that have gotten to
the top of big companies all staff
through consulting or
staff jobs
typically
more finance than than say the softer
ones like planning or
hr or pr
but
you know i i still think
that
setting out to build a record of having
been successful running something
where that success can be measured and
people recognize it is the best path
that i can find to uh
to to leadership
there there's a question i wasn't asked
yet at least today but i'm gonna i'm
gonna ask it and then answer it because
it gets back to setting the reset button
in your career and some of you here may
want to go and make a radical shift
uh
i don't know i don't know that to be
true but there's always some and if
you've been doing um you know consumer
products
and you want to you want to go
to tech
or even all big company and you want to
go to startup
and people ask me about
how
that kind of a desire
uh matches up with executive recruiters
and the answer is it doesn't
uh hardly at all
and so
and you will you will frustrate yourself
a lot
if in fact you're trying to make that
work because
99 times out of 100 it isn't going to
work
what the what recruiters want they want
an easy path to to a solution of a
client problem
and they've got a defined spec and let's
call it a
you know a marketing director position
for uh
pc apps business
okay
well who are they going to present as
candidates on that search they're going
to present probably three candidates
after after a work they want to present
that the top individual in that job for
their client company's biggest
competitor
or the number two person in a company a
lot bigger
um
or
somebody
two levels up
in a in a smaller company in the same
space or a closely related space
so
basically somebody that's done this job
before and can come in here and do this
job for my client fast
they're not going to present somebody
who was a finance manager
in a consumer project products company
that
got his mba and now wants to be a
marketing manager in tech it's not going
to happen
that
that job can happen but not down that
channel
it'll it if if you want to make a jump
shift like this is what we call a jump
shift
change of change of function
and change of industry
you're likely not going to get much
help
from the executive recruiting profession
to do that and that's just a fact and
i'm just i just want to tell you that
clear because don't waste your time
trying to convince them to do that
because
they're not
you got to go find that another way and
the way you find it
is typically by somebody who knows you
that's seen you work somewhere else
before and is in a position to say yeah
i know you've never done that before but
i know you can do it because i've seen
what you can do
that's not how that get that doesn't get
done through
a third party recruiter but it gets done
every day
through
your personal networks and your personal
contacts so if that's what you want to
do then that's what you got to work if
you know what you want to do and you've
done it and you've got demonstrable
record of doing it then there are
recruiters out there that are going to
jump all over you and try to get you
your next job
in that in that field either
either a jump
or a shift
same by a jump
higher level job doing the same thing up
from director to vp same industry same
function shift
same function different industry
director of marketing from consumer
products
to tech yeah probably if there's some
credible way you can do it so i'd call
that a jump or a shift but if you try to
do what in basketball or something they
call the jump shift which is change of
level and change of industry and
function change of function the change
of industry very very hard and you gotta
you gotta go work that on your own
um yes thank you thank you very much
that was my question but i have um
another okay
how do you um also to recruiters and to
future employees promote um the year
that you took here because i've got
mixed feedback and then we're like why
you already had a great career why would
you break that
and go and take an example like a
one-year program at stanford what is
like your best
answer to that apart from obviously the
personal reason okay what's your best
answer to that question
that i i wanted to um i had the
headquarters story i didn't want to stay
with my headquarter
so i needed i wanted to have a career
break i wanted to switch
not not my my function but unfortunately
my company because i didn't want to be
where the headquarters okay and i wanted
to use that time to really get some
educational aspects and a new
perspective okay
i'd say that story is fair
um i think you can improve that
and
i i think you would improve it
by being
more positive about
the
opportunity that you want to go to
and less negative about the one that you
were leaving
because nobody really wants to hear that
you know
that
i mean for example
you had learned all that you could learn
you knew you were missing some skills to
move up to the next critical level in
management and you thought this was the
most time efficient way that you could
add those skills and at the same time
enhance your career and move move to a
bigger job in a different company
because
you didn't see that opportunity where
you were to me that's a much more
positive story
uh some version of that uh again i i
think
um
nobody's gonna believe the story that
you tell them unless you believe it so
first off you have to believe it and you
have to be convincing and telling it but
to the extent that it's uh can be much
more positive
and and less negative this is your
elevator pitch and
you know
sort of like what you tell somebody if
they say you know
you know
you got two minutes tell me why i should
give you another 10 minutes uh you want
to have a really good story that you you
can tell when you do that and and i
would just say don't be defensive no
reason to there's not there's not a
reason in the world for any of you to be
defensive coming here you've made a big
investment of your life and your time to
improve your skills
dramatically i believe and i think most
people
uh would assume that
there are some nba haters in the world
some of them are vocal
some of them are active in the venture
capital community some of them have gone
out of their way to say that an mba is a
complete waste of time and money in fact
that a college education is a complete
waste of time and money you should just
go code
well easy for them to say because
they're billionaires but
you know
you probably are not going to get very
far convincing one of those people
that your time here was well spent
so i go back to the jim collins analogy
of the open door forget about those
people and go spend your time with
people who appreciate what you did here
and there's lots of them
and
you don't even have to take an editorial
position about who's right and who's
wrong
but i can tell you clearly one of them
is a much more likely
opportunity
set for you than the other one
without whether you agree with their
permits or not
if they think this is a waste of time
they're not going to help you go
somewhere else
yeah
okay
um i'm curious about what we would like
to say about compensation so i've had
some
words about compensation yeah
let me see if i can
if i can boil it down into a couple of
couple of key points
one is
ask a lot of questions
because the more information you have
the more the more power that that you
will have
um
compensation
has a lot more elements to it
typically than
most people identify at senior levels a
compensation package is going to have
maybe as many as eight or ten
major
components
we tend to think about
base salary
cash incentive bonus and equity grants
kind of the the big three
but
there's
relocation uh
you know allowances home buying programs
you know
pension gross ups signing bonuses
uh uh a special
project based
uh in incentive options and as many
things as people can can can dream up so
the first thing you wanna you wanna do
when you're in a compensation
discussion with anybody is find out how
many of those elements might possibly
come into play
you know do you have project-based
bonuses do you you know do you use
signing bonuses you know you know how do
you award you know option option grants
if i'm relocating how do you deal with
relocation is a home buyout part of that
blah blah blah and so now you've got
a framework of
of what's possible and there might be
something on that list
that could be really really valuable
to you
if you go to work for stanford your kids
get to get to go to stanford i mean
if you've got college-age kids i mean i
know people who have stayed here because
of that that's huge
you know and so
find out what the list is and then the
other the other thing i i tell people
um
a compensation discussion is a little
bit like working at a mixing board in a
sound studio you ever see these things
they got all these they're trying to
manage the sound probably there's a guy
back there behind the wall doing that
right now and you got about 10 levers
that that you know various
levels of the sound
you can't push them all to maximum
because you just get garbage it's the
same thing in a compensation discussion
you can't push everything to maximum but
you can probably push something
and one of the things that
is i tell people try to find the soft
money
if there is any i mean maybe
the individual you're talking to has a
severe salary cap and they just can't
go any higher
but they've got a lot of discretion
on a signing bonus
well money's money okay so you don't get
and so maybe you don't get that extra 25
or 50 000 in salary but you pick up a
hundred thousand dollar signing bonus
well that's pretty good because you can
have a salary negotiation again
in
a year but maybe you can negotiate it to
six months
and and get a review in six months again
what's the review cycle that's one of
the items on the list people don't tend
to think about so
you know
recognize at the end of the day that if
you push too many of the levers
you you could blow the deal
but you can push some and people expect
you to push somebody they they're i
think particularly
impressed
if you do it intelligently
particularly if you push something
that's not one of the one of the top
three and if you've done your homework
first off i mean at a minimum if you're
replacing somebody you should be able to
get everything that that individual got
because that's already been approved in
the system so that's a starting point
and and usually if you ask
you can find out
what that is
if you know what industry counterparts
that their competitors get for the same
job that's useful information
and so again do your homework
figure out what the elements are push
the the the one
that in in particular is worth more to
you to get than it is to them to give it
to you and that's where you can really
uh if you push on something where
they're resisting
that's going to be hard so go find go
find somewhere else to so it's another
version of an open door but it's go go
find something that's easy as opposed to
fighting over something that's hard and
i mean at the end of the day
i always
try to encourage
people in that negotiation
to try to get the company to accept that
you want to bet on your own performance
so go for
bigger upside on bonuses
shorter reviews project bonuses okay
i'll go in at this level it's a little
less than than what i want
in terms of salary but given that
is it possible that i i can have a
review of six months
and if the performance warrants i get
that adjustment
that's pretty soft they're not giving
much they're not giving away any money
they may well they may well agree to
that and if and if you perform then you
get it in six months if you don't
perform you're working to get it anyway
[Music]